طابور طويل وانتظار اطول تلك هي حكايه
معابر الحدود الافغانيه التسعه مع دول
الجوار
عند معبر ترخم بين افغانستان وباكستان تمر
يوميا الف شاحنه بين البلدين غلام محمد
جاء من مزار شريف شمال كابو انتظر عده
ايام عند المعبر حتى انهى اجراءات مرورها
فطور خانقه المرور في معبر ترخم يكون بحسب
الحظ انا مثلا بقيت خمسه ايام منتظرا
طابور لهذا اطالب بتسريع الاجراءات
الاداريه مع الجانب الباكستاني قبل يومين
تعرض سائق لنوبه قلبي وكان لوحده في
الشاحنه لم يعرف احد بامره الا بعد فوات
الاوان
اهم خمسه معابر في افغانستان تورخم وسبن
بولتك مع باكستان واسلام قلعه مع ايران
وحيرتان مع اوزباكستان ومعبر وشير خان مع
طاجاكستان فالعقبات الاقتصاديه الدوليه
على افغانستان
وتعقيدات التحويلات المصرفيه وزياده
الضرائب على التجار كلها عقبات تعرقل
النمو الاقتصادي للبلاد
الاعمال لا يستطيعون نقل اموالهم نقدا ولا
تمريرها عبر حدود باكستان
بانتظار دوريها الذي قد يمتد لايام وربما
سبع بينما يامل رجال الاعمال واصحاب
الشاحنات ايجاد طرق بديله اسرع علها تخفف
من وطاه الانتظار وتسرع عجله الاقتصاد
افغانستان وجدت بمشروع السكك الحديد
لتسهيل حركه نقل البضائع في بلد شاسع
بتضاريس متنوعه مع توقعات بزياده
الايرادات السنويه للمعابر من 750 مليون
دولار الى الضعف فور اكتمال مشروع السكك
الحديديه
فالتجهزات بدات بمد خط من مزار شريف وحتى
معبر تورخم مرورا بالعاصمه كابول وفي
مرحلته والرابعه الى كل من طاجكستان
والصين بواقع ثلاثه الاف و500 كم
بحلول عام 2005
الذي يربط العاصمه كابول بدول اسيا كما
انا بناء سكه الحديد سيحسن الوضع المعيشي
والاقتصادي وسيسرع من عمليه الاستيراد
والتصدير
تمكنت افغانستان بمساعده جيرانها من بناء
136 كيلومترا من مشروع السكك الحديديه في
بلخ وهيرات وفرياد تربط افغانستان
باووزباكستان وايران وتركمانستان مع
حاجتها القريبه الى انجاز نحو 650 كيلو
مترا اخرى لتغطيه جميع انحاء البلاد ناصر
شديد الجزيره من معبر ترخم على الحدود
الافغانيه الباكستانيه